is this America's racial reckoning
[Music]
through flames and fury a swelling
rebellion against prejudice and police
brutality reached boiling point all in
the middle of a pandemic the city now an
eruption of anger and activism it's
starting the revolution right now we're
gonna change everything
[Music]
killing us their target the virus that
has plagued this nation from the start
racism
[Applause]
[Music]
Washington the seat of American liberty
became a fortress soldiers on guard the
country on edge
Minneapolis is where it all began
whether death of George Floyd at the
hands of police ignited global outrage
there is despair and destruction
everywhere you look
but others see something else too a
tipping point there are parts of this
city that look apocalyptic that show
just how quickly frustration and
aggression spread they are a symbol of
deep anger could they also become a
symbol of lasting change the movement
pushing for progress feels different
diverse uncompromising sustained and it
brought white people to the streets in
numbers we have never seen before if
this is what you have to do to get the
thought process at least open okay down
with that you feel like you had to
destroy something in order we were
Michael Wilson is part of a new wave of
activists and his world changed
overnight
how would you describe the experience of
being black in America right now I feel
like we finally got some air I feel like
a cage around my body was just taken off
I feel like that six-by-six hole no
longer exists
I felt like now white people were taking
the other white people's hands off of my
head all those fingers that were there
for 400 years are now gone I now could
breathe let those cops now get convicted
and see what happens you thought that
this was a problem and you're hearing it
for me you thought this was the problem
let those cops get off mark my words
not only would they burn downtown down
every city in America will burn downtown
down how would you describe the
difference between what you're doing
your activism compared to what we saw in
the 60s with the civil rights movement
everything is exactly the same except
for one thing one one one one one these
things this is the graphic video those
things caught the nearly nine minutes of
suffering that shook America and three
words that will hold it where he died
protest lives
a place of energy and searing eulogies
what happened
Floyd happens every day in this country
and education and health services and in
every area of American life it's time
for us to stand up in charge his name
and say get your knee ohh
George's family knew him as a gentle
giant a father and a mentor others now
call him thank you for everything
please protest peacefully Cornish icons
of another era make their own pilgrimage
here feeling the winds of history effort
[Applause]
[Music]
oh it feels a lot different it feels
like a burden has been lifted off the
community it feels it feels a lot better
it feels like we've gotten some kind of
closure to a whole lot of things that
were happening in the in the past you
know because this this this brings us
back to the 1960s era racism has always
existed in American policy and policing
in the workplace
health care inequity rooted in slavery
some big Democratic cities are in a
reflective reactive mood but policing
and perspective is a very local thing in
the US and in heavily white suburbs like
Prior Lake you can hear the tension that
creates I don't think there's any white
privilege I worked my ass off to be
where I am from my perspective most of
my friend I've got a lot of friends that
are black and they're successful they've
never had a problem other than I can see
the profiling because it's it happens
you know it's just the way it is
profiling you'll never stop profiling
that'll never stop there's no way to
stop it it's a human nature there are
subtle shifts here though some haven't
seen before do you think conversations
are changing here yeah I do
I had people ask me questions that have
never asked the questions before so I
think what sometimes is stigma to not
talk about or no one realizes it's
something or scared to ask the questions
just being white is a privilege you
don't have to worry about if you're
gonna get stopped and pulled over and
what's going to happen you don't have to
worry about anything to be treated
equally for a job you don't have to
worry about if they're gonna hire you
because of the color of your skin you
don't have to you know think about how
you talk or what you say or how that
comes across to someone Leslie has been
on the other side and living in the
epicenter of this story she's finally
ready to talk about it
this has been hard
and I'm not being quiet anymore
I mean that's that's the biggest thing
is
you fear saying anything because you
don't want to be the angry black woman
or the fiery latina or the you know
whatever name the the stereotype and
it's just so you don't you don't let
yourself have any emotions and that's a
lot to weigh on yourself other things
where I had a teacher who would call us
they're supposed to say children color
but they called us colored children and
would like separate us in separate
groups between the colored children and
the white children to make it even and
you know I was like seven so I didn't
quite understand but I knew it was wrong
it messes with your soul then you start
to question all the time is it
or is it just the way they see me if
watching George's life leave his body in
a way that it did and watching for
police officers stand over him and it
exact power over him and in a way that
he couldn't couldn't respond if that
it's just one more like one inch closer
to check in our white privilege checking
the the the assumptions that we've had
checking the the things that we say like
that hopefully it's not in vain in just
two weeks eleven cities have banned the
police room using the controversial
chokehold method to detain suspects
Minneapolis City Council voted to
disband the police force
nationally Democrats have proposed
sweeping legislation that lengthy ball
video helped bring relatively quick
prosecution's justice will likely be
slow but public pressure may be here to
stay what happens here was about more
than the suffering of just one man it
exposed a collective trauma and it also
gave african-americans powerful proof of
what they have always known but others
have been unable or unwilling to accept
[Music]
black people have been at the sharp end
of everything in America coronavirus has
only reconfirmed that the George Floyd
has inspired soul-searching across
generations capturing a nation after
decades of denial far more ready to
change direction
[Music]